♪ ♪
>> Gregg: AND WELCOME BACK TO
THIS "HANNITY" SPECIAL.
FOR OVER 25 YEARS, OPERATION
CHRISTMAS CHILD HAS SPREAD
CHRISTMAS CHEER TO CHILDREN IN
NEED ALL OVER THE WORLD.
THE PROJECT IS PART OF THE
CHRISTIAN RELIEF ORGANIZATION,
SAMARITANS VERSE.
AND UNBELIEVABLY, IT HAS
COLLECTED OVER 168 MILLION GIFTS
FOR CHILDREN IN MORE THAN 160
COUNTRIES AND TERRITORIES.
SEAN RECENTLY SAT DOWN WITH CEO
OF SAMARITANS FIRST, FRANKLIN
GRAHAM.
HERE IT IS.
>> Sean: HERE IT IS NOW, THE
CEO OF SAMARITANS FIRST.
OUR GOOD FRIEND FRANKLIN GRAHAM.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
DO YOU THINK YOU WERE SUCH AN
INCORRIGIBLE CHILD TO YOUR POOR
FATHER.
YOU TURNED OUT OKAY.
I HAD THE PLEASURE ONE YEAR OF
GOING ON A TRIP WITH YOU AND
WHAT WAS AMAZING ABOUT IT IS
THAT IN THIS BOX IS LIKE, HEAVEN
FOR ALL THESE KIDS.
AND IT MAKES A DIFFERENCE.
HE CAN'T BELIEVE WHAT A
DIFFERENCE IT MAKES.
>> WHAT WE ASK IS WHEN A PERSONP
>> WHAT WE ASK IS WHEN A PERSONC
>> WHAT WE ASK IS WHEN A PERSONS
>> WHAT WE ASK IS WHEN A PERSONA
>> WHAT WE ASK IS WHEN A PERSONB
>> WHAT WE ASK IS WHEN A PERSONX
>> WHAT WE ASK IS WHEN A PERSON,
>> WHAT WE ASK IS WHEN A PERSONB
>> WHAT WE ASK IS WHEN A PERSONY
>> WHAT WE ASK IS WHEN A PERSONO
>> WHAT WE ASK IS WHEN A PERSONR
GIRL, BUT PRAY BEFORE YOU SEND
US THE BOX.
PRAY FOR THE CHILD WHO IS GOING
TO GET THE BOX.
I DON'T KNOW WHO IS GOING TO GET
THE BOX.
GOD DOES.
BUT I WANT EVERY CHILD TO KNOW
THAT GOD LOVES THEM.
I WANT EVERY CHILD TO KNOW THAT
GOD IS REAL, THAT HE CARES FOR
THEM, AND I WANT THEM TO KNOW
THE TRUE MEANING OF CHRISTMAS
AND THAT IS THAT GOD SENT HIS
SON JESUS CHRIST TO THIS EARTH
TO SAVE US FROM OUR SINS.
>> Sean: LOOK AT THIS, IS THIS
FOR A BOY?
>> THIS IS FOR A BOY PURITY OF
THE SOCCER BALL, YOU HAVE THE
PUMP
>> Gregg: TO PUMP UP THE
BALL.
>> JUST SOME TOYS.
>> Sean: CRAYONS, CARS AND
STUFF.
AND THEN YOU ALSO PUT IN SIMPLE
STUFF LIKE A TOOTHBRUSH.
>> AND A LETTER IN THERE FOR THE
CHILD.
PUT YOUR PICTURE IN THERE
BECAUSE WE WANT THE CHILD TO SEE
WHO GAVE THEM THE BOX AND THIS
HAPPENS TO BE MY YOUNGEST SON
WHO JUST GOT OUT OF THE MILITARY
AFTER 16 YEARS OF SPECIAL
OPERATION.
HE'S COME TO WORK WITH ME, SO WE
ARE PROUD OF THAT.
THESE ARE JUST A SIMPLE ITEMS
BUT IT MEANS EVERYTHING IN THE
WORLD TO THESE KIDS.
AT THE SAME TIME, IT OPENS UP A
DOOR FOR US TO BE ABLE TO SHARE
GOD'S LOVE WITH THEM.
YOU AND YOUR FAMILY WENT WITH
US.
YOU SAW FOR YOURSELF.
>> Sean: I WILL BE HONEST, TO
SEE THE REACTION.
I MEAN, MY CHRISTMAS, IT WAS A
BICYCLE, SOMETHING REALLY BIG.
BUT TO SEE THE REACTION ON THE
KIDS' FACES, I MEAN, IT KIND OF
TAKES YOUR BREATH AWAY IN A LOT
OF WAYS.
I GUESS WE TAKE FOR GRANTED,
RIGHT, MAYBE IT'S NATURAL, ALL
THAT WE HAVE.
>> WE DO.
WE ARE A VERY BLESSED NATION.
BUT THIS IS A WAY THAT A FAMILY
CAN DO SOMETHING FOR ANOTHER
FAMILY HALFWAY AROUND THE WORLD
AND IT IS SO SIMPLE.
THESE ARE NOT EXPENSIVE ITEMS.
BUT FOR MOST CHILDREN, IT'S THE
ONLY GIFT THEY'VE EVER HAD IN
THEIR LIFE.
>> Sean: IT'S CRAZY.
>> IT JUST OPENS UP A DOOR WHERE
WE CAN TALK TO THEM AND CARE FOR
THEM.
>> Sean: THEY LIGHT UP LIKE
NOTHING I'VE EVER SEEN.
HOW MANY BOXES DO YOU THINK YOU
WILL DELIVER THIS YEAR?
>> THIS YEAR WE WILL BE A LIVE A
>> THIS YEAR WE WILL BE A LIVE L
>> THIS YEAR WE WILL BE A LIVE T
>> THIS YEAR WE WILL BE A LIVE E
NORTH OF 11 MILLION BOXES.
>> Sean: WHAT IS THE RECORD?
EVERY YEAR IT GROWS?
>> IT GROWS EVERY YEAR.
MAYBE A FEW HUNDRED BOXES, MAY
BE MORE.
>> Sean: YOU CAN BUY A BOX,
MAYBE ONE LIKE THIS ONE HERE.
DO YOU PROVIDE THE BOXES?
>> WE PROVIDE THE BOXES, WE ALSO
HAVE PAPER BOXES FOR THE PLASTIC
ONES ARE BETTER.
BECAUSE IT IS A GIFT AND LONG
AFTER THESE TOYS ARE WORN OUT,
THEY STILL HAVE THE BOX.
>> Sean: YOU GET A GIFT FOR A
KID AND ALL OF A SUDDEN THEY
LIKE THE BOX MORE THAN THE
PRESENT.
SO HOW DO PEOPLE DO THIS?
>> THEY CAN GO TO
SamaritansFirst.org.
GO TO OUR WEBSITE.
WE SHOW THEM HOW TO PACK A BOX.
THE ITEMS TO PUT IN A BOX IF
THEY ARE A GIRL, OR A BOY.
JUST SUGGESTED ITEMS.
THEN WE HAVE THE INSTRUCTIONS ON
WHERE TO TAKE THE BOX, HOW TO
MAIL THE BOX.
>> Sean: HOW MANY COUNTRIES DO
YOU GO TO YOURSELF?
DO YOU DELIVER A LOT OF THESE?
>> I WILL GO TO A HANDFUL OF
COUNTRIES.
WE GO TO OVER 20 COUNTRIES.
>> Sean: AND YOU HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES IN ALL THESE
COUNTRIES?
>> EVERY COUNTRY WE HAVE A
NATIONAL LEADERSHIP TEAM THAT IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR TAKING THE
SHOE BOXES AND DISTRIBUTING THEM
OUT TO THE CHURCHES.
WE DELIVER THE BOXES TO THE
CHURCHES IN THESE VARIOUS
COUNTRIES, SO LET'S SAY A
COUNTRY GETS 100,000 BOXES.
A PARTICULAR COUNTRY.
THE NATIONAL LEADERSHIP TEAM IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THAN DIVIDING
THOSE 100,000 BOXES AMONG THE
VARIOUS CHURCHES.
THEN WE HAVE A SUGGESTED
PROGRAM, BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY WE
HAVE ANOTHER PROGRAM AFTER THIS
IS OVER WITH, A DISCIPLESHIP
PROGRAM FOR THE CHILDREN WHO
WANT TO LEARN MORE ABOUT GOD.
IT'S A 12 LESSON DISCIPLE
PROGRAM IN THIS PAST YEAR
WE HAD A LITTLE OVER 4 MILLION
CHILDREN TAKE A 12 LESSON
COURSE.
AT THIS YEAR WE WILL HAVE A
LITTLE OVER 5 MILLION TAKING
THIS COURSE.
>> Sean: YOU ARE TRYING TO
MAKE UP FOR ALL THE TROUBLE YOU
CAUSED YOUR DAD.
THIS IS YOUR WAY OF SAYING, I'M
TRYING TO MAKE UP FOR BEING THE
INCORRIGIBLE TROUBLEMAKER THAT
DROVE REVEREND BILLY GRAHAM
NUTS.
>> MY MOTHER DIDN'T LET ME GET
BY WITH NOTHING.
>> Sean: I HATE TO TELL YOU
BUT I WAS A LOT MORE
INCORRIGIBLE THAN YOU, BUT THAT
IS FOR ANOTHER DAY.
THIS IS A GREAT CAUSE.
GO TO SamaritansFirst.org.
THANK YOU FOR WHAT YOU DO TO